dream and I clicked back to the
tournament I didn't realize that starts
the game automatically so I accidentally
started a game which I guess I have to
finish because I'm in the tournament I
can't really abort it so it looks like
everyone's still watching let me refresh
the page it's complete accident on my
parts oh there's no one watching
beautiful I guess I'm just talking to
myself now I didn't really want to play
more chess but I also don't want to lose
my life perfect score in classical chess
on me chess so I have to persevere in
this game each six is a very strange
move there's not he can't castle let's
play f3 solid and we might get some
position where I'll probably end up
castling queenside and he's probably
gonna start storming on the on the Queen
side with like b5 a 5 typical perk ideas
I'm actually curious here if I can if I
can leave my king of the center play a
four and just slow him down let's try
this well I play a four I'm basically
saying I won't Castle queenside it's not
kind of mixing mixing a couple ideas
this whole setup is slightly
contradictory where I've developed my
whole Queen side first the the knight
the queen the bishop almost like fully
committing to Costin Queen side and then
I played a four so but he's in a weird
situation too because he played aged six
and he can't Castle kingside
so this is going to be a weird game
I'm just gonna complete developments I
was about to play Bishop d3 but he is 96
night before I play Bishop c4 he is d5
I just want to play h4 and see what he
does
hmm okay let's play h4 I could be super
ambitious and play like g4 go for some
attack u5 I don't think quite works
caudillos night h5
actually not entirely happy with this
position she won't split five next
that's annoying but he can't castle I
have to keep that in mind if he can't
castle it's snowing for him too
let's play Bishop c4 the theory is that
if I just put my pieces on it squares it
can't be that bad
please me five so if I take I could take
with Knight more pod could drop back to
you three yeah let's drop back
mmm drop back he takes I could take with
Queen
if I take on e5 first it'll take on e5
first I see if he takes what tonight I
just went upon really Bishop to e5 pawn
to g5 Queen take and I went off sudden I
think you just missed that I thought I
was gonna be a kind of a shark game but
this is what happens when Queens could
get traded just hop up on g5 I can't
believe can be a good move because I
take we trade Brooks Bishop is stuck on
a Jade's start Crete linking okay and
castling queenside kind of plays itself
I'll play 92 can't you seven make sense
so this is probably going to go into
some end game where I'll just be trying
to convert up a pawn he might have some
compensation with the two bishops
hopefully not too much I'm liking this
pawn on e5 because it's just keeping
this bishop in a very bad spot and it
will probably never make sense for me to
play a four he wants to reroute he
probably wants to play something like
Bishop h6 so I'm thinking why not just
forget one so there's to open files in
this position but there's very few entry
points there's no entry points and on
the D file or the H file at least in his
territory and welcome to the the one
viewer I see it just jumped from from
one to two viewers on Twitch one viewer
is me so whoever just watched on our
joined on Twitch feel free to leave a
comment I was not intending to do the
stream but I accidentally started
started a second tournament game so I
have to finish this before I end the
strain
this is a type of position like I have
to figure out what to do ball is in my
court I really want to put an eye on e3
and I think I can get away with that
somewhat easily the problem with my t1
here's B 5 I start with my g3
yeah let's play that g3 you can't play
b5 right away I have some ideas of
playing 9f 193 or 91 93 let's just train
rooks and we're gonna get into some lawn
and game which I don't know if it's
winning but white should have good
chances
so the first the first step is just to
make sure everything is solid
he has no like stupid tactics this could
this could come down to time to QC to
now the one good thing about having the
Knights against the bishops is the pawns
are kind of concentrated for the most
part on the Queen side with fuse I guess
so called center pawns
so bishops shouldn't be too powerful
I'm really just waiting here I don't
speak clear plans so I'm going to do
some manoeuvring hopefully something
comes up b5
let's play b3i one downside with b5 is
pawn is now fixed on a5 it's kind of a
permanent weakness and if he if these
pawns ever get traded I'll have ideas of
night b2 night c4 and I would think that
his say this that his a5 pond is weaker
than my a for pot but we'll see
time is probably gonna be very important
sometimes the way the better side will
win this position is by by by pressuring
the opponent with time and in this case
it's hard to pressure the opponent on
time when he has six minutes and I have
three minutes I'm happy to have the see
force where that's going to be a
beautiful thing for a knight
here's a lot of isolated ponds so it's
technically all those ponds are
potential weaknesses the problem is my
bishop can't really attack anything I
thought my bishop can try and exploit
some of the weaker squares I mean the
b-52 5f5 so it's kind of an interesting
situation it's played Bishop c4 here you
know I would very much like to trade off
white sweet bishops
[Music]
it's actually kind of annoying move
let's play Bishop I don't know if I want
to go into an obstacle or Bishop ending
so I'll do this I'm not entirely happy
if we go into a LightSquared bishop
ending if if he takes on d2 I take on d2
so the downside is most of my pawns are
fixed on light squares which will favor
him in some regard I have to plate there
should be two here
now of course I'm always the one playing
for the win it's just about maximizing
my winning chances and he has some some
problem to deal with with this might c4
idea
I'm realizing if he takes on D 2 and E 5
could be a bit weaker can I just win a
pawn here take or I might see for no
foot not sure if it matters which Knight
to c4 leaning towards this night the
other night bull potentially come to d3
I'm not two pawns okay
I might as well just trade down unless
there's a better option might be three
kings e6 well let straight down a little
bit
now the still the issue is this extra a
pot is sort of meaningless this extra a
pawn could be what wins the game it's
gonna play king b3 but Bishop e6 is kind
of annoying play a five I think I see
anything wrong with that
if he plays Bishop e6 I've night to be
six and his King is is restricted from
attacking the pawn and now the goal is
suddeniy play Knight d5 the bigger goal
is to knock flag and then the third goal
is to activate my king I would love to
trade off I don't know if that works
let's play this it could be pretty sure
that any sort of night versus Bishop
ending where I'm just off to pawns as
his winning
okay he goes for it's slightly annoying
I think I have 93 it's restricting
keying b5 and now the goal is just to
activate my king if I allow king b5 it
could have been annoying but once I come
to c4 I can get back into the game and I
think one minute is plenty of time to
win this just have to figure out the
right night path let's do this idea is
night a one night p3 and then attack c5
let's go this way towards the center now
Knight III attack c5 and c5 and he's not
gonna be able to define both I take if
he plays him v6i for him
just as tiring to look energy to in that
game we go back here's a weird opening I
can't imagine how h6 could be good but I
was interesting just to see what White's
plan is so I kind of had to commit to
doing something here and I've castling
queenside maybe it's very easy for him
to play and just leave the king of the
center but okay we got to this queenless
middle game where he was just down the
pond and I think I was just in control
the whole game but then the end game was
interesting because it seemed like he
should be should have been able to put
up better resistance but I guess I'm
somewhat pleased with the manoeuvring
like the Knights worked together to come
to c4 and there was nothing that's
enough pressure to win another pawn and
convert anyway that's been a lot of
chess for me today I'm gonna take a
break
might be back later it might be back
tomorrow or later in the week anyway for
whoever's watching adios I will see you
guys in the future bye